لم تحسم النتيجه حتى الان هذه الساعه
الاخباريه من العربيه لمتابعه نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه ما ظهر الان
من هذه النتائج يبينوا ان التنافس حاد
للغايه بين الحزبين فلا سيطر كامله حتى
هذه اللحظه اهم ما كشفت عنه النتائج هو
منصب مقعد شيوخ في ولايه بنسلفانيا الذي
فاز به المرشح الديمقراطي جون فترمان على
الجمهوري محمد اوس هذا المقعد كان يشغله
سيناتور جمهوري متقاعد بالتالي
مهم من يد الجمهوريه لكن حتى الان
لم يتم حسمها لاين من الحسبين في يسيطر
الجمهوريون على 48 متر عددا ويسيطر
الديمقراطيون على مثلهم حتى تنتهي
الانتخابات في النهايه بيعاده الوضع لما
كان عليه قبله هذه الانتخابات الولايات
المتبقيه حتى الان في مجلس الشيوخ والتي
لم يتم اعلان نتائجها هي جورجيا اريزونا
ويسكينسون ونيفادا ما تنبئ به التوقعات
حتى الان ان الجمهوريين سيفوزون بمقعد
ويسكن صن الذي يتنافس فيه السيناتون
جونسون مع الديمقراطي مانديلا باركرز وفي
اريزونا اقرب الظن ان السيناتور
الديمقراطيه ماركلي سيفوز على المرشح
المدعوم من ترامب لك مع السلامه
ستشهد معارك قانونيه محتدمه بعد
الانتخابات وذلك لاغلاق لجان انتخابيه
اغلاق ابوابها اثناء يوم الاختراع بسبب
المشاكل القانونيه ينحصر اذا الصراع الذي
همم سيحسم مجلس الشيوخ في ولايتين هما
جورجيا وكذلك في طبعا في الجنوب الشرقي
وكذلك نيفادا في الغرب الامريكي حتى الان
يتقدم في جورجيا سيناتور الحاليه رافائيل
على المرشح المدعوم من التمر هاشم فرز
الاصوات لكن
لا نتائج نهائيه نكرر الا النتائج نهائيا
نيفادا يامل هناك الجمهوريون ان ينتزعوها
من يد الديمقراطيين كما انتزع الحزب
الازرق من سلفانيا
لكن بعد فرز نحو الثمانين في المئه من
الاصوات يتقدم المرشح الجمهوري ادم حتى
الان بنقطتين مئويهتين يمكن ان نقول ان
مجلس الشيوخ في اغلب الظل ذهب الى تقسيم
المقاعد بالتساوي بين الحزبين هاي العوده
الى المربع الاول قبل انتخابات لكن نعود
ونؤكد مجددا هذه مجرد توقعت
[موسيقى]